good evening my name is Robert Duncan
assistant manager here at Barnes & Noble
in Woodmere
we'd like to welcome you and our friends
at c-span who have joined us tonight
Kent State
Ahmir words alone still polarized
segments of our nation not unlike
Vietnam which still divides us as
witnessed by the most recent
presidential election in which the
shootings at Kent State are closely
linked to Kent State is with an out
within an hour of here the 35th
anniversary of Kent State that day is
reflected on the cover of the book we
are about to discuss to help us
understand the events at Kent State and
how it changed us we welcome Philip
Caputo who has written 13 seconds a look
back at the Kent State shootings mr.
Caputo is a renowned journalist who has
won the Pulitzer Prize and is perhaps
best known for his work a rumor of war
one housekeeping note please if you have
any cell phones turn them off now so
we're not interrupted there will be a
question-and-answer session after mr.
Caputo's presentation please wait for
the microphone to be given to you before
you asked your question then we will
have an autograph session following the
question-and-answer session with no
further delays please join me in
welcoming Philip Caputo I thought I
would begin by just explaining what this
book tries to do and why it's been
written at this time aside from the
obvious fact that the Kent State
massacre as it has come to be called
will mark its 35th anniversary tomorrow
one of the strange things I had noticed
oh I'd say it was about a year and
perhaps a year and a half ago was that
whenever I mentioned Kent State to
people who were old enough to have
remembered it remembered it and to have
been emotionally affected by it would
have rather
vague memories of it they would remember
that there was some violence in the
campus at Kent State that some students
were killed but they weren't quite sure
if it was by police officers or by
National Guardsmen and this sort of
surprised me I as you will see when I do
a bit of a reading from this book I had
I had covered the events there though I
arrived at the campus about two hours
after the shootings two to three hours
after the shootings had occurred which
is how this subject would come up in
conversation so what together with my
agent and with the editor Carlo DeVito
of Chamberlain brothers which is a
division of penguin Putnam we got
together and decided to do this in
effect package as you know as you can
see it contains a DVD of an Emmy
award-winning documentary now I don't
want to talk myself down here but in
fact this documentary is is really
really good and it's terrific and it
actually goes in interviews participants
it interviews survivors and interviews
eyewitnesses a lot of other people and
recreates the event in a way that you
could never do on a printed page
obviously because it's a visual medium
what I wanted to do in this was simply
to take the record that does exist about
Kent State and to put it together in as
concise of form as I could so that
people in the general public would be
able to access at least the fundamental
facts of what had happened there now
that's not all this is it's not just a
compendium of facts or a khole
nation of magazine newspaper articles
archives at Kent State University and so
forth it is also description of what I
did when I got there something of a
reflection on what the atmosphere in the
country was like then and I also draw a
comparison between Kent State and the
one other event in American history that
most closely resembles it and that was
the Boston Massacre which occurred
exactly two hundred years and two months
before the Kent State massacre March 5th
night 1770 so that just gives you a
brief overview of why the book was
written and what it seeks to do I I want
to emphasize that I did not try because
I didn't think and I'm quite sure I was
right that to unearth new information I
think it would be very very difficult if
not impossible given the many
investigations that occurred into this
incident to find anything new at this
late stage of the game so it makes no
pretenses along along those lines I
think that with that said I will read
excerpts from the opening chapter to you
after which I will then take your
questions
driving i-76 through Akron in the heart
of the heart of the Midwestern Rust Belt
I am trying to remember which route I
followed from the Cleveland Airport
nearly 35 years ago it isn't important
but I want to withdraw even the small
details from the vault of memory
I don't recall taking an interstate I am
fairly sure there was none
linking Cleveland and Akron back then my
recollection is of a two-lane blacktop
leading through the Ohio countryside
past barns and farm houses and plowed
fields and dog woods sprouting white
blossoms in the soft light of an early
May the exit signs read Kent Ravenna
Kent State University I turnoff to drive
north on route 43 which could be the
highway I took in 1970 but from the
opposite direction there are no dogwood
blossoms today it is late October the
trees blazed like fireworks and the
countryside has changed is indeed no
longer countryside most of the barns and
farm houses have been razed subdivisions
grow where corn once did fast-food
franchises car dealerships shopping
malls muffler and brake shops sprawl
across former pastures for all practical
purposes once rural Kent now belongs to
exer BIA the herb of being gritty Akron
10 or 15 miles away the car radio
crackles with news of the 2004
presidential race the campaign is in its
final frantic week and the two
candidates are storming Ohio a
quote-unquote key battleground state in
media shorthand President Bush will
we'll be speaking in the Cleveland
suburbs and in Dayton Challenger John
Kerry is to be in Toledo before heading
on to a rally that will be led off by
the boss Bruce Springsteen I cannot help
but think of the news that Monday in May
the bulletins that inter
regular programming that is how I had
heard about it on a car radio and I
remember stepping on the gas racing down
the two-lane blacktop toward the
University where the Ohio National Guard
had opened fire on a crowd of student
demonstrators wiped the countryside the
campus has changed dramatically it is
bigger with more buildings and more
roads blue and white signs direct
visitors to the north south and east
campuses I am not sure which one to go
to
until I spot a sign that says May 4th
Memorial with an arrow pointing to the
right there is another farther on and
then no more and I am soon lost parking
near the Ice Arena a low almost
windowless building of pale brown brick
I check a campus map in a glass tin box
on the corner the key alongside the maps
informs me that the Memorial is near
Taylor and Prentiss halls some distance
from the Ice Arena Taylor Hall that
flips a switch in my memory I returned
to my car
stepping over the words celebrate
responsibly painted on the sidewalk at
regular intervals
I assume this is an admonition not to
get drunk and rowdy after a hockey game
but it may mean something else entirely
at any rate the students appear
admirably sober and responsible on this
fair autumn morning as they stroll to
and from classes and baggy clothes
backpacks stuffed full of books
a security guard directs me to a
visitor's parking lot I get out walk up
a dirt path and see Taylor Hall and
imposing concrete structure atop a hill
it was one of the newer buildings on
campus in 1970 now it has attained
venerable status though its architecture
nondescript 20th century modern belies
that description it still looks new
the hill slopes down in a sweep of green
to a green field that must be the
practice field where the guardsmen knelt
and fired with our world war ii m1
rifles
it is quite peaceful today empty banal
below i spot what appears to be a marker
walk to it and discover that it is
merely a piece of sculpture somewhat
frustrated i climbed back up and asked a
student is the memorial around here
right over there he says pointing at a
clump of trees
it is unobtrusive to say the least
almost covert hidden under a grove of
oaks and maples a marble tablet set in
the ground near some marble slabs that I
guess serve as benches the sole
decorations are a few artificial flowers
bound with pink and purple purple ribbon
a foiled pinwheel penned pin wheel that
turns lazily in the breeze the blades
silver on one side painted with the
stars and stripes on the other its
modesty seems deliberate as if it
commemorated a dark secret
like the gravestone of a relative that
shamed the family the tablet is covered
with dead leaves which I brush off to
read the chiseled legend in loving
memory alison krauss Jeffrey Miller
Sandra Shore William Schroeder
respectfully remembered Ellen Ken fora
John Cleary Thomas grace Dean Kaler
Joseph Lewis Donald Mackenzie James
Russell Robby stamps Douglass rent more
for all its uninspiring nature it is a
kind of war memorial honoring the
casualties of the day when the Vietnam
War came home there are four other
markers in the prentice hall parking lot
near Taylor Hall one for each of the
Dead I have a vivid memory of that
parking lot stained with their blood and
the blood of the wounded and I carry it
with me as
leave the campus and drive through Kent
its business district like most in
American small towns half ghost town
half Museum vitality sucked out by
Walmart's and Home Depot's then head
down wrote route 43 for the interstate
my brain reeling back in time as the car
rolls forward I then describe how I came
to Kent State I was then at that time in
1970 a reporter for the Chicago Tribune
which I went to work for shortly after
being discharged from the Marine Corps
where he had served in Vietnam in the
mid-1960s
for the first few years I was a foreign
correspondent for the Tribune for the
last five years I was with him with the
first five I was a local reporter and
and I had covered a number of events
that were signal events of the 1960s for
the Tribune for example I had covered
the Democratic National Convention the
the days of Rage that the weatherman's
staged in Chicago the Murrah the
shooting of Black Panther leader Fred
Hampton also in Chicago Chicago was seem
to be quite an epicenter of a lot of
this at that time and so on May 1st
was the day after President Nixon had
announced that he had ordered American
and South Vietnamese troops to invade
Cambodia it was called then an incursion
just one of those bizarre euphemisms but
it was basically an invasion by at least
25,000 Allied troops this sparked a
nationwide reaction and
disturbances and demonstrations on
campuses across the country mostly
because Nixon had pledged to withdraw
the United States from America and in
fact that was underway the process that
was called the vietnamisation which was
turning the war over to the South
Vietnamese government and army and this
seemed to be as in fact in many ways it
was an escalation of the conflict rather
than a diminishment of it and so one of
the campuses that saw the that that
experienced disturbances and unrest of
course was the one at Kent State and
that was on May 1st and then they
disturbances continued through May 2nd
and May 3rd on the morning of May 4th I
was called by the National desk because
and I'll describe what happened there
rather than just tell you I'll read it
this way before reporting into the
newsroom on Monday morning I got a call
from the day city editor
thus the disturbances in Kent Ohio had
grown serious over the weekend store
windows had been smashed in town
radicals at burnt burned down the ROTC
building firemen had been driven off by
mobs slashing hoses and throwing stones
and the Kent City police were unable to
cope with the situation the Ohio
National Guard had been ordered in and
were now occupying the university the
national desk wanted me to get there
immediately evidently my coverage of the
University of Illinois demonstrations
the month before qualified me as the
paper's campus protest correspondent
well my first question was where the
hell is Kent State I had never heard of
it informed of its location this is my
Chicago provincialism if you'll excuse
me informed of its location I booked the
next available flight to Cleveland
packed the bag said goodbye to Jill my
wife and drove to O'Hare Airport during
the hour-long flight I read a wire
service story to bring myself up to date
Ohio's governor James a road
had blamed the disturbances on
quote-unquote outside agitators I had
learned to be skeptical skeptical about
such claims but was willing to set my
skepticism aside the burning of the ROTC
building was right out of the weather
Underground's handbook
except for that and it was no small
exception the protests appeared to be
like those at Illinois maybe there was
one other difference Illinois Governor
Olga V had taken pains to calm the
situation at champaign-urbana governor
Rhodes adopted the opposite a combative
approach at a press conference on Sunday
he had compared the protesters to Nazi
brown shirts describing them as quote
the worst sort of people we Harbor in
America unquote and promised to quote
use every weapon possible to eradicate
the problem unquote a bit of political
grandstanding perhaps Rhodes was then
involved in a tough primary fight for
the Republican Party's Senatorial
nomination but it struck me as an
inflammatory statement my memory is
patchy I believe the shootings took
place while I was flying to Cleveland
and that the report I heard on my rented
cars radio was an update my immediate
reaction was the one you would expect I
was stunned the next one the next was
also one you would expect from a newsman
though it now makes me cringe to recall
it this is one hell of a story and I'd
better get on it doing at least 20 over
the limit I arrived in Kent when a
horror occurs in a commonplace setting
the horror is magnified Kent could have
been a college any college town at any
part of the Midwest the usual girdle of
motels and restaurants and the outskirts
usual elm shaded streets lined with
clobbered and shingle sighted houses in
the usual student beer halls with the
usual names downtown it was at the gate
to the University that the unusual
appeared an armored personnel carrier
the unit's designation stamped in white
on its olive green steel 107 CAV roads
had sent in the cavalry as if the
demonstrators were hostile sue further
on I encountered a barricade man by Ohio
State Troopers their patrol car
windshields tape to prevent shattering
in case they were hit by rocks
a trooper asked for identification I
showed my tribune press card and was
waved through driving on the atmosphere
of unreality thickened the campus was
deserted the university having been
closed students and faculties sent home
in their place where national guardsmen
in full battle dress rifles loaded
bayonets fixed some troops were lined up
for chow at the mess area near the
gutted ruins of the ROTC building others
marched in formation down the sidewalks
closer to the scene of the shooting
Taylor Hall and the practice field below
it soldiers had taken up combat
positions squatting behind trees or
lying prone scanning the field in the
parking lot as if looking for snipers
the overall impression was of an oak of
an occupied town in some as-yet-unnamed
war no problem finding a parking space I
walked to the practice field where I had
spotted a civilian the only one around
he was young and a jacket and tie not a
student in other words I went up to him
thinking he might be a faculty member he
turned out to be another reporter John
Kipner from the New York Times a
newspaper superpower then as it is today
The Times did not regard a regional
power like the Chicago Tribune as
competition still I fought Kipner was
quite generous to give me a thorough
fill in when what had happened that will
be described in more detail later in
this narrative but for now I'll confine
myself to a summary of what kiff 'nor
told me several hundred demonstrators
kiff Marzette had gathered on the
Commons at noon on May 4th for a
scheduled anti-war rally several hundred
more were cheering them on
watching them and a troop of National
Guardsmen posted nearby the guardsmen
were ordered to disperse the crowd and
did so firing tear gas canisters after
clearing the commons the guardsmen
marched to the practice field protestors
were gathered in the prentice hall
parking lot others stood in front of
Taylor Moore tear gas was fired to which
students responded by throwing stones
and shouting obscenities at the
guardsmen the action was over in five or
ten minutes
protestors and spectators began to
straggle off an officer ordered the
soldiers to return to the commons area
as they did some students continued to
hurl rocks and four-letter words
suddenly a line of Guardsmen wheeled and
making no distinction among active
demonstrators by standards and students
merely walking to class melt and fired
killing for wounding nine I have given
the dry facts
kiff nerd gave me then and the dry facts
alone were shocking the response to a
provocation cannot always be
proportionate but to answer stones and
bad language with a random volley of
thirty caliber bullets was not
imaginable in America or maybe it was
because America had changed I mentioned
two Kipner hearing on the radio that the
guards adjutant general had said that
the troops fired after they had been
shot at by a sniper
kiff nurse shook his head no witnesses
had heard a shot nor hit he and he had
been with the students nevertheless
Guard officers had seized on
quote-unquote evidence that there had
been a sniper on the roof of Taylor Hall
this was a bullet hole in an abstract
steel sculpture at one end of the field
we went over to look at it a bullet hole
all right
but you didn't need ballistics training
to see that the round had been fired
from ground level it had come from a
soldiers rifle alone I went to the
parking lot and in the clean spring
light Saul saw still distinct
bloodstains in the asphalt whose I
wondered which young life had leaked out
to soak into this dull pavement I heard
an echo from the days of Rage what do
you want revolution when do you want it
now well this is what revolutions look
like this is what they come to bayonets
bullets and blood the blood of innocence
and do you still want it now or at any
time this chapter then goes on to
describe interviews I had with a wounded
with with a wounded student and then my
attempts of that evening and the next
day especially to interview Guardsmen to
piece together some picture of what had
really happened by this time the fantasy
of the sniper had pretty much been
dispelled as a reason for the guardsmen
having opened fire it was quite obvious
to everyone that there had been no
sniper so the new story was that was
promulgated by guard leadership was that
these guardsmen were in mortal danger
and in fact their commanding general at
the time Brigadier General Robert
Canterbury said that that the situation
was dangerous and I felt I could be
killed he said that in a press
conference which all of us attended on
the campus I then left the Kent the
press conference and went to the mess
hall or the mess area to see if I could
find anybody who might have been with
the detachment that that did the
shooting I didn't find anybody there
that was willing to talk but I did find
someone who was with a unit of Guardsmen
that were virtually right next to the
one
that did the shooting and I'll just
describe that it's fairly brief the
press conference over I went to the mess
area found a lieutenant who had
commanded a platoon on the hill by
Taylor Hall and asked for his version of
events I have a vague recollection of a
man of about 25 with reddish hair and
freckles but my memory could be wrong he
granted an interview on condition I not
use his name I have a clipping of the
story I wrote and this is what he had
told me quote we were surrounded and
outnumbered ten to one you should have
seen those animals they were trying to
take our rifles away someone in the
crowd yelled that we were only carrying
blanks so the students assaulted up the
hill while others tried to outflank us
by going around the rear of Taylor Hall
unquote viewing their situation as
desperate he went on 17 Guardsmen turned
Sun dropping to one knee the rest
standing and without orders loosed a
thirty five shot volley it would be
determined later that the actual figures
were 28 soldiers and 67 shots but the
lieutenant's statistical inaccuracy
could be overlooked what struck me was
his choice of language surrounded
outnumbered ten to one assaulted up the
hill tried to outflank us it almost
sounded like a scene from the movie Zulu
The Thin Red Line attacked by hordes of
spear carrying savages I recall thinking
this is complete crap no one else I had
spoken to had seen students attempting
to disarm the guardsmen they weren't
close enough even if they had wanted to
and by the way the closest student was
60 feet away but all the rest were
anywhere from a hundred to two hundred
and fifty yards away
no one had heard a yell that the
soldiers had blank rounds and their
rifles and the picture of college kids
conducting a complex military maneuver
some making a frontal assault while
others conducted a flanking movement was
pure fantasy from my experience in
Vietnam I knew something about real
combat and what it was like to fear for
your life and I felt angry if the
guardsmen had perceived themselves to be
in danger then something was seriously
wrong with their perceptions or as was
more likely with their training
discipline and leadership the lieutenant
was lying to me because he was lying to
himself creating a story he could live
with or maybe to protect himself and
others from legal action as a journalist
I had to keep my opinions to myself but
to my mind the guardsmen had panicked
and committed manslaughter or reckless
homicide before they were dispatched to
Kent State
they had quelled a Teamsters Union
strike in Akron Teamsters are more
formidable adversaries than
undergraduates and the strike had been
marked by deadly violence including
gunplay between striking truckers and
strike breakers thrust from that to a
campus in turmoil seeing the ROTC
building burned to the ground
the part-time soldiers had been tired
and on edge nor can one ignore the
effect that governor Rhodes is vowed to
use every weapon to eradicate the
problem must have had on them I thought
the Kent State faculty had it right in a
resolution passed on May 5th condemning
the shootings quote we hold the
guardsmen acting or acting under orders
and under psychological pressures less
responsible than our governor Rhodes and
adjutant general Sylvester del corso
whose inflammatory indoctrination
produced these pressures unquote and I
will I could read more um if you want
but I thought I would stop there that
seemed to be I was doing this yesterday
in Chicago and this morning in Chicago
and I'm running out of throat but I
thought at this point I would see if you
have any questions which I be happy to
answer
hey could you speak up loudly I was
waiting for the night they told me to
wait for the oh there it is okay
I am I BLET your book wallet we know a
couple about maybe a week ago and I've
read I've been reading through it and I
watched the DVD and it is it's it's it's
excellent
I was donek and I was wondering in the
book I didn't notice it yet but do you
speak about also the ROTC building or
the ROTC one of the contentions on the
college campuses also was the presence
of ROTC on campus because I remember
them chanting ROTC now because I'm going
to kids down the Kent State I was
enrolled in can stay but I was going
part-time at at the Extension Center but
every not have to go down there and just
before this either SDS or weathermen
dressed in fatigues were just they were
talking and ranting about ROTC this and
every other I mean it was the F and I
mean you can imagine at the time and
everything at the man this is getting
really yeah if I mean like you said Kent
State this middle in the middle of the
country geez you know and you know and I
was just wondering if if there was
something going on between that and then
the idea of Cambodia just intensified
the whole thing because I've talked to
two veterans we had already been in
Cambodia anyway I mean there were secret
missions into Cambodia before this
weren't there oh yeah there were secret
missions yeah but with the emphasis on
secret in this case here this was it was
a little hard to keep 25,000 troops
crossing the border and secret ec issues
I'm just wondering you know ROTC I mean
that was an issue in the anti-war
movement and in fact The Weather
Underground as it came to be called had
called the previous year 1969 yeah when
they were formed
you know they got their name from that
old Bob Dylan song and the subterranean
homesick blues you don't need a
weatherman to tell you which way the
wind blows are they they had called for
the
attacking symbols of establishment or
military authority which included ROTC
buildings so that that yeah that
definitely was was an issue the the
thing that the Cambodian invasion did
was is that it reinvigorated or rien
flamed depending on your point of view
the anti-war movement that was that was
that was where Cambodia came in yeah
mr. Caputo I was wondering as a Vietnam
veteran how you felt about student
protesters at the time that students
were protesting the war and I was also
wondering after the war to today how you
feel about them as your opinion changed
because of what we now know about the
war
well I assumed everybody hear the
question
I'll make sure about that I was I
actually when I got back when I got out
of the I got back from Vietnam in 66 I
got out of the Marine Corps in 67 by
that time I turned against the war so I
might not be the best person to talk to
about that because by and large I agreed
with those who were protesting against
against the war to be candid about it I
didn't like a lot of them I kind of
thought that that those of us who
actually fought there were the only ones
who really had a right to protest it and
I sometimes found a lot of the students
to be insufferably self-righteous which
i suppose is a privilege of being 19 or
20 and looking back on it I do go into
that a bit in the book is that I even
then and and and I still do and perhaps
even more vigorously now than then I
vigorously disagreed with the people who
were advocating violence those anti-war
demonstrators who were like The Weather
Underground was saying blow blow things
up burn things down shoot people for
example a Jerry Rubin I think it was
Jerry Rubin he came to the Kent State
campus about a month before the
shootings occurred that he was not an
SDS weatherman but he was certainly an
icon of that particular political woman
he got up and in front of a crowd
he was invited to speak there and he
urged them all to get weapons and kill
their parents now even then the students
kind of looked at him and said this
guy's a real this guy is way beyond the
edge but you can imagine the effect that
this would have on the parents so that
sort of not only inflammatory rhetoric
but those violent actions I strongly
disagreed with I thought those I thought
most of those people that were on that
edge of the anti-war movement were
deranged if anything so and and that's a
feeling that I that has not changed and
say for anything it's it's it's
intensifying yeah I have to say that
only in America usually can you protest
against something you don't agree with
and not get killed and I can say to that
I was at Kent State and I knew two of
the kids who got killed I have the
yearbook with me I think you'd find it
of interest but you know the things that
happened there were wrong at that time
very wrong and I can tell you that on
the 25th anniversary or maybe it was the
30th but I go back occasionally to Kent
and so I went to Kent and they had
speakers for everyone who was killed
come up on stage and this is how the
person who was with alison krauss when
she got killed described things amongst
many other things he said that they
heard shots he started running they were
just walking to school to class and they
finally got behind a car and that's when
he realized that she had been shot in
the back and so the innocent people who
got killed no matter what you thought at
the war and their radicals and I'm sure
that Jerry Rubin went to many many
campuses and said the same rather
bizarre type of things but that should
have never happened at Kent State
and also Taylor Hall it doesn't have
rocks and stones there you would have to
bring them in to do any kind of damage
to anybody and if you look at the
placement of where the students were
standing when they got shot it
definitely was as you said or basically
I could say a random killing spree yeah
and in fact by the way is that one of
the I mentioned at the beginning of the
talk that a lot of people had forgotten
details or maybe never even knew them
but that two of the students that were
killed one sandy Scheuer was was
changing classes and the other William
Schroeder who was for all practical
purpose this this guy walked out of the
all-american boy handbook was was was
was watching it's paused to watch the
demonstration and he would he had
nothing in other words nothing to do
with it
so it was as you said an act of almost
ran random violence and the one of the
students I had interviewed one of the
wounded I think it was rent more and
said that the largest stone he saw
thrown in him was about about half the
size of a golf ball and and you're right
I don't I don't really quite know since
I wasn't there at the moment that it was
happening I know where they got these
stones even but yeah to two of the
students that I knew sandy sure I was a
little sister to fraternity with and
then William Schroeder he dated one of
my best friends three months prior and
he was a member of ROTC yeah he was he
was not only a member of wrought ROTC
but he was a he was an honor student in
fact I just just a second I thought I
saw somebody else but I'd maybe I didn't
okay go ahead
to talking about the stones at the time
there was a construction site also on
one side of where the guard was when
they marched into the they they they got
themselves
between the two fences there was a
couple of fences and there was a
construction site and what they were
trying to say was that students were
throwing becomes of concrete at them
which but as you said as you
investigated it would have been
impossible these things were so heavy
you couldn't have thrown him no you
don't want to begin with you know what
chunks of concrete right
I'm just saying directions but that's
the that's what that's what Brigadier
General Canterbury and I think I first
tried to say is that they were taking
these huge slabs of concrete flinging
them at the guardsmen and so the nearest
the nearest kid was 60 feet away well he
would have had to have picked up a slab
of concrete and thrown at 60 feet which
I would say that I wouldn't want to mess
with that guy ever if he could do that
if I could talk about the veterans as
you as a veteran and how you felt about
the college students now in my own
personal experience I had been in the
service in the Air Force I got out at 63
and I began to go I was against the war
fly me from 65 and when we first sent in
the first 5000 troops and we protested
peacefully and we didn't buy you know
what you're talking about this rhetoric
to weather men and I think there was a
distinction to be to be a made between
protesting the war but treating the
veterans of the war as they came back as
soldiers who were doing their duty and I
know we didn't appreciate and even go
along with this baby-killer I'm sure you
heard so when you got back to us that
was wrong I mean we were trying to
destroy you for being getting these guys
out of there that was they all saying of
blaming the warrior for the war and
that's the one thing I think there was a
I think that's where a lot of resentment
from I can't speak for them because but
a lot of the Vietnam veterans is the
resentment they felt coming back that
they were over there doing their duty
and here they were being treated like I
mean like crap I mean to put it you know
and that was wrong that was I that was
certainly agree with you on that yes my
brother was in Vietnam and I was very
happy that he got back three times
Purple Heart
and he never said too much about it and
he lived with my husband and myself
because we can have parents eyes were
gone and I would see shrapnel all over
the soap all the time I mean it was and
he never spoke too much about it at all
and today if he speaks about he does
come to tears he was in the America of
division and the tanks and know war is
good and I can understand why we are
more now I detest it all and I hope
today I don't think you're gonna be able
to go out there and protest too much
against the war not with what they're
doing down in Washington how they're
changing everything it's uh it is
terrible it's all I want to sort of
however stick to this oh I knew we were
gonna drift into that particular subject
but that's that's that's like that's a
completely different venue let's say
yeah there's a question back here have
you had any contact with the parents of
the children who were killed no no I
have it as as I as I was pointing out
earlier on is that the actual reporting
on the survivors of survivors families
and so forth like that
I left to the to the documentary and
this so I haven't had any contact with
feed yes in the documentary yeah not not
with all of them but with some of them
has it ever been established the
percentage after investigation of how
many of the protesters were actually
students and not outsiders I've heard so
many stories about well there yeah there
were a lot of there were people from
that were not Kent State students that
were
yeah that were involved in now whether
it was the demonstration on May 4th or
the disturbances in town Robert yeah
that there were students from Ohio State
there were junior college there were
high school students some of them mixed
in yeah rowdy people from out of school
for a number of years were they're all
in the right in the front of it was this
gal in the picture show while showing
the problem you she was a teenage
runaway she was she was she was naughty
she was not a student right she was at
first and then when the initial news
reports came out she was identified as a
student everybody made that assumption
but in fact she was only 14 going on 15
this I spent 6 years in the National
Guard 15 years oh it was I was out 15
years before the Kent State student
however I worked for 40 years in Canada
at lamb electric I was in town at
bowling banquet that night I did not see
what went on downtown but I do know this
our unit that we had at the time was not
trained we were trained by people that
we did the training ourselves out of
manuals the people that were very
untrained
and the ones that did the majority of
this shooting were not local they were
from Akron acronyms Copley in
surrounding areas I know knew quite a
few of them they were old mostly younger
than I was at that time because I joined
when I was 17 and I had already been out
15 years when this took place
but I I just hate to see the National
Guard being run down when they're out
there right now protecting us all
yeah well I'm you know this is not to
run down the National Guard as an
institution no it's not I mean this is
we're writing about or I'm writing about
a an event that actually occurred and
and the Scranton Commission and the eff
the Scranton Commission that was
appointed by President Nixon that was
headed by then ex governor of
Pennsylvania
Scranton a Republican by the way as
Nixon was and the FBI all concluded that
this particular unit it was troop G of
the hundred and seventh cavalry had
fired without any justification
whatsoever that they were not in danger
that there was no justification for
doing what they did now that is a fact
now it's you know to say that this
particular cavalry troop which amounts
to what 80 or 90 people at most acted
acted the way they did is not to say
that the entire National Guard is a
composed of murderers not properly
trained no and I go into that in here
they were I that in fact one of the one
of the positive things if I can call it
that that came out of this event was
that subsequent to that National Guard
units as well as law enforcement units
became much better trained in crowd
control and handling civil disturbances
a watchword that became was almost
became nationwide was we don't want
another Kent State so I mean I don't
agree with it but there's some yeah sure
I know the guard is fighting over in
Iraq right now
and I just want to stress that however
you know in the interests of not be
smirking the National Guard is an entire
institution
I cannot gloss over what actually
happened 35 years ago tumors questions
that I had asked was there ever a lead
investigation was it ever established
how many were outsiders and how many
were true students all investigations
just focused on that sup that question
of an investigation focused on that
question well in that yes
no there was so nobody really knows
nobody nobody knows other than the
investigation that did occur did
determine that there were that there
were people on all 1 2 3 4 days of the
disturbances at one time or another who
were not Kent State students now some of
them were Kent State High School
students I mean I can't stick if anybody
remembers the old puffs truck stop in
streets borough I don't know but it was
one there and they I was in there one
night when about three of those that
have been down there going down every
night just to raise hell and joining
that group there and in aggravating and
everything else that come in there and
talk about it all brag all over that oh
I know you know but you know I can tell
you you know what you're doing though
seriously you're you're leading up to
justifying shooting you yeah I can tell
you are no I'm sorry I don't want to
argue with you but you but you're saying
yes these kids and those demonstrators
were obnoxious they were foul-mouthed
they were a lot of things that I don't
find particularly pleasant myself but I
covered a lot of demonstrations in in my
day before that and I saw law
enforcement officers and and National
Guardsmen to behave with firmness but
with restraint and the fact that you
know that that that I that I say the
f-word to you I maybe use an analogy
it's not a perfect analogy but you and I
were in a bar and I said fu to you and
you said you can't call me and you pull
out a gun and
not me I got a feeling that if you told
the cops that guy said a dirty word to
me you you'd be arrested for murder and
there's no justification for shooting me
because I used the nuts
I used obscene language I don't think I
could shoot somebody if I had well no I
I don't want to argue with you but
anyways was they were not trained
properly to begin with so they didn't
know probably what they're doing I mean
I think that they didn't know what they
were doing also I think it was a bad
choice to take guys that had been
battling if you want to use that phrase
these Teamsters four days and had no
sleep and nothing like that and put them
into a volatile situation like that it's
you know you would think that you could
get somebody else there I know the Ohio
National Guard is bigger than that yeah
it does Hill and you've got the closest
person 60 feet away so certainly they've
been trained well enough to know the
difference between shooting warning
shots and shooting into a crowd that 60
feet away I have a problem justifying
that
well it wasn't justified as I said now
the FBI concluded it wasn't justified
and the Scranton Commission among others
concluded it was not a not anywhere near
a justified shooting and by the way out
of the 28 Guardsmen that fired their
weapons they fired 67 shots in 13
seconds the
FBI and I'm trying to remember how what
other law enforcement offices were
involved in this determined that
probably out of that twenty eight only
eight actually fired directly into the
crowd the others had fired into the
ground or had fired warning type shots
into the air and it was it turned out
that eight were and out of that eight
five were indicted but were were
exonerated in a crit in the criminal
case so I just want to point that fact
out is that not all of them were fired I
got a feeling if you had twenty eight
people firing directly into a crowd like
that a lot more than four would have
been killed
yeah
I don't want to monopolize but I'm
directing this to the lady back there
also and you mentioned it about the
blanks and I had heard that some of the
professor's had told the students that
the National Guard would not show up
with loaded weapons and it was as he
said a colonel what mean he I mean that
the students were I mean to them it was
the the tear gas that they were throwing
the windage shift that was going back
into the National Guard and they were
throwing the tear gas back at them yeah
and with all of this and the the story
that I'd heard that some of the
professor's had said to the students
well you know they don't they're not
going to show up here with loaded
weapons they don't they have blanks in
it so I again I don't want to monopolize
but I just thought it do you see now
that's the rumor or whatever that I
heard I'm sorry what I'm saying is these
were things that I heard at the time
myself you know then afterwards and I
couldn't find in the record that I
looked at I could not find any record
there that anybody in who knew better or
was in authority told the students
they've only got playing the blank round
story was kind of an urban legend among
the student body where at where and how
it got started I don't know but there's
nothing that I know of in the record
that says a faculty member or several
fact memory says don't worry about it
they've only got blanks I think the
assumption was was that they did not
have live ammunition or if they had it
that it would that their rifles were not
loaded but in fact the general had just
not long before they went off to clear
the Commons had ordered them to what's
called Lock and Load which is to pull
the bolt back on the rifle and chamber
the round into the and take the round
out of the magazine and chamber yeah
what was the response of the community
people who lived in the community
my impression had been that they were
very they were down on the students yeah
is that correct well I cannot speak Kent
at that time had a population of 27,000
people so you know I can't tell you I
didn't do then nor have I seen since a
scientific survey of what what their
attitudes were most of the ones that I
ran into were very down with students in
fact there were a couple of people said
I wish they had shot more of them and
you could see why a lot of them were
angry this this goes I mentioned this in
the book is that I regard what happened
at Kent State as a tragedy that was the
result of a collaboration they have had
many authors now I in my opinion the
principal authors were the two was were
the governor and the inflammatory
statements he made and the and the the
two senior officers that were in charge
there but also contributing to this I
thought were those students who had
turned to violence in the sense that by
burning down the building the ROTC
building by trashing businesses in town
they had contributed to a very tense
violent atmosphere so you know I when
some of those people made comments like
that they probably made them in passion
and in rage but you know that I saw
their hardware stores or I can't
remember exactly what some of the
businesses were but these are ordinary
small towns small businessmen who worked
all their lives to build up a business
and then somebody comes along starts
throwing bricks through the window and
smashing all your stuff up and says
you're part of the establishment you
know you're an establishment target like
like a hardware store owner can
determine what policy is in Cambodia so
we should never lose sight of the fact I
think it's one of the things that I try
to leave people with at the end of this
book is that what Kent State was in
addition to being that a collaborative
tragedy was an example of what happens
when passions get out of control and I
don't care from what side you're looking
at whether it was the students the
students passions at least not all of
them but some of them were out of
control and the reaction to them was out
of control and that's that's certainly
an impression I try to get across is
that you know that we're all responsible
for for for for our actions starting to
sound preachy responsible for their
actions yeah
well if there's nothing else yeah just
last summer we stumbled upon the Kent
Memorial we went to the ice hockey arena
for a different situation and real I
realized we were there what really
struck me we went up to the memorial and
there's collateral literature put out by
the University if you set aside the
thirteen tragedies the collateral
material is put out by the college which
I would have thought would have been
extremely sympathetic to the student
body is it very unsympathetic to the
entire student body not not the thirteen
that were wounded or killed but it it
almost or maybe it was my perception of
what I was saying was saying that so
much but you said the provocative miss
and all that that happened and it may
just be a reflection of what the
community in general feels but being put
out by the university I would have I
would have been much more slanted
towards the poor student body had been
put in jeopardy and it almost went the
other way to wear it I didn't see that I
mean I the only pieces of literature
I've seen from the university has been
in their archives of May 4th but that
did not strike me as being overly overly
critical so I don't know why this must
be something else that I did not see
what I was saying I was saying it wasn't
as sympathetic as I thought it would
have been towards its own constituency
and they weren't archival things this
was a Saturday or Sunday so there were
small pieces of hand out literature that
you can get right there at that hall no
I didn't I was just surprised to find
out that it I don't even know what the
source of it was the school but it said
it was school organizations I'm just
surprised to see there was that
unsympathetic oh we go
hypothetically it hadn't happened at
Kent State given the fervor of the day
do you think it probably would have
happened on other campuses there were
other uprisings on multiple campuses
right well as a matter of fact it did
after Kent State it did happen at
another campus at Jackson State
University in in Jackson Mississippi two
weeks later two more students were
killed now those were disturbances that
were caused by racial friction Jackson
State was a black Teachers College yes I
I as I look back on that era there's no
way for me to prove this it's just
simply a feeling that there was a almost
a almost like a toxic atmosphere that
had built up in the country and I think
that what happened at Kent State was
what inevitably would have happened
somewhere somewhere if not at Kent State
I still find what's remarkable is is
that it didn't happen at those campuses
that we associated as radical hotbeds
Berkeley Columbia the University of
Chicago and such places is that it
happened at a mid-sized Midwestern
campus that was not a radical campus by
it by and large as a matter of fact you
know just not long before that the the
the demonstrations in response to the
Cambodia invasion there had been some
SDS students on the tents at the Kent
State chapter that tried to was it no
they they they were going to not exactly
attack but they were going to break up a
meeting of the board the the University
Board of Chancellor's and make some
demand and seven hundred students had
actually turned out and turned the SDS
aside and so they were they were that
conservative so it seemed strange that
this
a thing would happen at a campus like
that but it did never wants to answer
your question I think I think it would
have it was just building up to that
okay well with that thank you very much
for your comments
[Applause]